am Sonntag punkt 18 Uhr da geht der
Blick nach München und Wiesbaden Bayern
und Hessen wählen einen neuen Landtag
und spätestens dann aber mit der ersten
Hochrechnung dann schauen alle wieder
ganz Link nach Berlin wird die Ampel
abgestraft werden haben Diskussionen
über Zahnbehandlungen letztendlich
geholfen oder geschadet was nützt der
Linken was der AFD in beiden
Bundesländern waren Migration und die
wirtschaftliche Lage die wichtigsten
Themen um die auch heftig gestritten
wurde und rund um die flugblatt-affäre
des freie wählerchefs Aiwanger ging es
auch der zu scharfer Ton im Wahlkampf
wie entscheiden Bayern und Hessen unser
Thema in der Phönix Runde
Phoenix Runde
guten Abend ganz herzlich willkommen aus
Berlin das sind meine Gäste Janina Mütze
begrüße ich herzlich Gründerin und
Geschäftsführerin von seaway das ist ein
Unternehmen das Online-Umfragen in
Echtzeit erstellt Professor Jasmin
Riedel ist bei uns Professorin für
Politikwissenschaft an der Universität
der Bundeswehr München und unter Einsatz
von künstlicher Intelligenz der
analysieren sie alle deutschsprachigen
Tweets zur bayerischen Landtagswahl wir
sind gespannt ich begrüße Eckart Lohse
er ist Redakteur in der politischen
Nachrichtenredaktion der Frankfurter
Allgemeinen Zeitung berichtet hier über
die Berliner und die Bundespolitik aber
hat natürlich auch den hessischen Blick
Professor Thorsten FAS ist hier
Professor für Politikwissenschaft an der
Freien Universität Berlin und er
analysiert regelmäßig vor Landtagswahlen
die Übereinstimmungen der Parteien die
dann ihre Informationen in den Wahlomat
einspeisen
Sonntag 18 Uhr da wissen wir dann was 14
Millionen Wähler wo sie und WählerInnen
ihr Kreuz gemacht haben wie wichtig ist
dieser Abend dieser Sonntag Vortrag für
die Politiker hier in Berlin also wir
haben ja schon gesagt 14 Millionen
Wähler die sich die wählen könnten oder
können ist nicht alle tun werden
hoffentlich viele an das ist natürlich
weil
auch Bayern mitwählt also sozusagen die
die CSU-Spitze auch zur Disposition
hätte ich fast gesagt steht zur Wahl
steht eine besonders wichtige Wahl
andererseits ist jetzt schon
einigermaßen absehbar dass die
Konstellation vermutlich nicht komplett
auf den Kopf gestellt werden und uns mal
vorsichtig zu sagen aber wenn so viele
Wähler dabei sind ist das automatisch
wichtig und wir erinnern uns vor 5
Jahren bei der Hessenwahl hat Angela
Merkel am Tag danach gesagt äh das
Schluss ist mit ihrem Parteivorsitz und
ist auch die letzte Runde als Kanzlerin
ist also solche Waren können auch wenn
das jetzt nicht zu erwarten ist können
natürlich auch
Überraschungsmomente bundespolitische
Natur zur Folge haben die Union schauen
aber doch mal die Frage auf die Ampel
gucken
immer damit mal an dann verliert die SPD
in beiden Ländern in Bayern weil sie ja
nie besonders stark neun Prozent da
steht es jetzt eine Umfragen grüne um
die 15 und die FDP muss ja um den Einzug
bangen also ist es vor allen Dingen für
die Ampel jetzt und ja so ein Stresstest
ja im Grunde genommen gibt es ja wenn
man die beiden Wahlen und die drei
ampelpartner anguckt also sechs Fragen
die sie stellen könnte es sein oder wird
es möglicherweise so sein dass die
Grünen in Hessen an der Macht bleiben
und ein erträgliches Ergebnis haben und
ansonsten wird das Ganze für die Ampel
ja nicht so furchtbar schön wenn für die
FDP blöd läuft fliegt sie aus weiteren
zwei Landtagen raus die SPD haben sie
gesagt einstellig in Bayern die
bundesinnenministerin hat Anlauf
genommen Ministerpräsidentin in Hessen
zu werden im Moment sieht es nicht so
aus als würde vor fair sein das werden
also ein richtig schöner Abend wird es
für die Ampel wahrscheinlich nicht ein
bisschen bei der Ampel Frau Mütze also
wie sehr ist die Meinung über SPD FDP
und Grüne sozusagen entscheidend auch
für diese Landtagswahlen
ja das ist
klassische Frage an die timoskopie die
man natürlich nie eindeutig beantworten
kann ich glaube grundsätzlich gilt dass
ich keine Landtagswahl von einem
Bundestrend vollständig lösen kann der
fließt immer mit ein und der ist wie
auch gerade schon beschrieben sicherlich
nicht besonders gewinnbringend gerade
für die Ampeln wir sehen das wirklich
jetzt sehr sehr deutlich in den Zahlen
der letzten Monate dass diese
stapelkrisen etwas mit den Menschen
machen in der in der bundesweiten
Bevölkerung dass die Zuversicht zunimmt
im Land sinkt negative Emotionen wie Wut
und Unsicherheiten das Gefühl irgendwie
ist dann Kontrollverlust vorhanden
solche Gefühle nehmen zu und man hat das
Gefühl in der Bevölkerung dass die
Bundesregierung nicht die Themen
adressiert die ihr besonders wichtig
sind also da ist scheint so ein Mist
Mensch dazu finden in der Kommunikation
zwischen Regierenden und regierten und
ich denke das wird sicherlich auch etwas
sein was wir am Wahlsonntag dann sehen
werden dass man an den Schuh auch
irgendwie oder den äh das ist vielleicht
die eine andere subtile schulterweise
und danach nach Berlin geben das ist ja
dann immer so das wenn es gut läuft es
hat freut sich Berlin und sagt das haben
wir dank unserer Politik und wenn
andersrum geht es dann wieder
durcheinander so erfasst also wie wie
relevant ist die Entscheidung oder ist
das was die was die Ampel im Moment hier
leistet und die schlechten Noten die Sie
hier bekommt für die Wahlen nein das
setzt auf jeden Fall die Grundstimmung
für eine solche Landtagswahl denn machen
wir uns nichts vor Landtagswahlen
Landespolitik ist jetzt nichts was
wählen Wählerin Wähler Tag ein Tag aus
umtreibt und insofern ist das erstmal
wenn man so will die als Ausgangsniveau
auf dem dann ein solcher Wahlkampf
aufsetzt ich glaube die Besonderheit ist
tatsächlich dass wir mit der
Innenministerin der
bundesinnenministerin tatsächlich dieses
Mal eine Akteurin haben die aus der
Bundespolitik kommt und das ist
tatsächlich spannend und neu weil es die
Konstellation die wir dann Hessen
erleben schon ändert eigentlich hat der
Ministerpräsident meine riesigen
bekanntheitsvorsprung in der Regel auch
einen gewissen beliebtheitsvorsprung und
das ist in Hessen dieses Mal sehr sehr
anders sehr besondere Konstellation
sicherlich findet ihr aber das ist schon
so ein Testballon glaube ich auch ob ein
solches Modell eine bekannte
Bundespolitikerin ein landeswahlkampf zu
schicken ob das Potenzial hat bin ich
sicher ob das die Lehrer am Ende sein
wird besonders wichtig ist die Migration
ist jetzt eines der entscheidende Themen
für die sie ja auch hier in der
Bundespolitik steht ja absolut wobei es
für die SPD wiederum schwieriges Thema
ist weil das ein Thema ist bei dem die
wählerinnenschaft der SPD tatsächlich
eher gespalten ist also das ist nichts
womit man SPD Wähler in der breit der
Partei mobilisiert sondern im Gegenteil
das hat für die SPD auch durchaus
Spalten das Potential also ambivalent
das ist gerade die Innenministerin ist
die jetzt dort in den Wahlkampf geht wir
schauen mal mit ihnen nach Bayern sie
analysieren die tweetster zur
bayerischen Landtagswahl was haben sie
da beobachtet naja also zum einen muss
man sagen Tweets oder jetzt auf X ist es
so dass der Ton im digitalen Wahlkampf
tendenziell negativ ist das ist nichts
was jetzt nur für den bayerischen
Wahlkampf spielt sondern das Geld auch
für frühere Wahlen die wir analysiert
haben auffällig ist aber zum einen also
auch noch mal mit Blick auf die Ampel
also Sie diese diese Haltung dass sich
umso Wahlen zweiter Ordnung jetzt
handelt in Bayern also dass die
ampelregierung im Bund sehr deutlich
sozusagen angegriffen wird dass er so
ein Gegner erzeugt wird gerade die
Grünen das ist was was im bayerischen
Landtagswahlkampf sehr präsent ist
zumindest auf Seiten der Parteien die in
der Ampel in der Opposition sind
sozusagen also CSU Freie Wähler AFD das
sind die Parteien die da deutlichen
Wahlkampf gegen die Ampel im Bund machen
und das andere was sehr deutlich
sichtbar ist obwohl der Ton tendenziell
eh immer ein bisschen negatives sehen
wir jetzt das ist doch noch mal
zugespitzter hitziger aggressiver
wütender auch gegen Politikerinnen und
Politiker wird aber eben auch so eine
der Wahlkampfstrategien das Negativ
campaigning auch sehr beliebt ist und
ähm ja häufig darauf zurückgegriffen
wird also der Ton wird härter wir haben
es gab Meldungen dass die grüne
Spitzenkandidatin dass sie dann
verstärkten polizei-schutz bekommen wir
haben aber auch Meldungen gestern
gelesen dass alles Weidel von der AFD
ein Wahlkampfauftritt abgesagt hat aus
Sicherheitsgründen Herr lose ist das was
man sagt das ist jetzt sieht man ja in
der ganzen im ganzen Land dass sich der
Ton eben verschärft also nicht typisch
für Bayern und Hessen sozusagen ich
glaube das sieht man im ganzen Land das
hat natürlich viel mit mit den sozialen
Medien auch zu tun also so eine
Enthemmung findet da eher statt ein
Wahlkampf tut noch trägt noch was dazu
bei aber man merkt natürlich schon wie
das auch aufgeheizt wird vor allem gegen
die Grünen das ist ja nicht nur in
sozialen Medien auch ansonsten zum
Hauptgegner erkoren von Friedrich Merz
und also das ist aber ja jetzt nicht neu
für diese beiden Wahlen sondern dass der
Ton ähm
rücksichtsloser rauer wird persönlicher
verletzender das erleben wir schon lange
können wir natürlich die Gegenbeispiele
anbringen wie sie Politiker auch schon
vor 50 Jahren beschimpft haben aber es
ist ja jetzt die Masse aber das ist
Facebook das kann halt jetzt jeder
aber was also man sieht schon seit
Jahren dass der Ton so ein bisschen
rauer wieder wird aber ich würde schon
argumentieren dass zumindest jetzt für
den bayerischen Landtagswahlkampf zum
einen es nicht noch mal nur deutlich
rauer ist und und sozusagen gegen
bestimmte Parteien Stimmung gemacht wird
also gegen die Grünen jetzt in dem Fall
sehr deutlich sondern es ist tatsächlich
sehr aggressiv zum Teil und also das ist
eine Sache ist dass es sich auf sozialen
Medien zeigt auf der anderen Seite sehen
wir aber auch dass tatsächlich
Wahlplakate rassistisch beschmiert
werden das auf Wahlplakaten
bestimmte Symbole oder sprayfarbe so
drauf ist es aussieht wie ein Kopfschuss
und das ist jetzt auch nicht nur
irgendwie wo man sagt na ja Mensch jetzt
ist der Ton gerade ein bisschen rauer
sondern ich würde schon sehr deutlich
argumentieren dass ich dass das in
ernsthaftes Problem ist und das all
diejenigen die sozusagen in diese
populistische Schiene hinein
argumentieren das befeuern ob das jetzt
in Bayern in Hessen oder im Bund oder
sonst so ist es sei mal dahingestellt
okay und welchen welche Folgen hat das
zum einen in Bayern ja die werden wir
bei den Grünen bleiben ist gerade von
von Aiwanger und von März das sind
sozusagen unsere Hauptgegner auf der
anderen Seite aber in Hessen Boris rein
der
Ministerpräsident der Union ja mit den
Grünen regiert seit und die Union dort
seit zehn Jahren mit den Grünen regiert
also wie kommt denn das Frau mit zu wie
wirkt denn das dass man auf der einen
Seite sagt das sind die Gegner auf der
anderen Seite regiert man mit denen ist
natürlich zwei unterschiedliche
Zielgruppen die angesprochen werden ne
also in Bayern wird Politik für die
Bayern gemacht wer war Wahlkampf findet
in Bayern statt sondern in Hessen eben
für Hessen und er findet ihr in Hessen
auch geräuschloser Stadt als in Bayern
das muss man ja auch sagen das sehen wir
auch sehr deutlich dass man auch in
Bayern das Gefühl hat das Landespolitik
eigene Themen und auch eigene Kandidaten
viel stärker als den wahlentscheid
beeinträchtigen als in Hessen
beispielsweise deswegen würde ich da
jetzt gar nicht so einen großen
Widerspruch sehen was wir sehen ist dass
die Bevölkerung ist als zunehmend
kritisch bewertet dass Politik
unkonstruktiv streitet also also
konstruktiv streiten ich nehme jetzt was
Beispiel Migrationsfrage ohne ein
Konsens herzustellen dass es gefährlich
wenn also Streit der in zu einer Lösung
führt das wird das Gewürz gewürdigt wenn
wenn das aber offen bleibt man das
Gefühl hat da geht es auch gar nicht
mehr darum eine Lösung zu finden das hat
natürlich das Potenzial dass dann eben
ganz andere politische Kräfte irgendwie
ein Aufschwung gewinnen können er war so
wie sehen sie dass diese
unterschiedliche Behandlung der Grünen
weil die jetzt gerade wie wir gehört
haben auch besonders scharf angegriffen
werden
regionale Frage oder was ist das
de facto Markus das sein aber so kommt
es natürlich überhaupt nicht rüber
sondern es macht diesen Eindruck von
Unglaubwürdigkeit natürlich schon noch
mal stärker wenn ich auf der einen Seite
mit einer Partei regiere und nicht nur
in einem Bundesland wenn man ehrlich ist
sondern der durchaus in mehreren
inzwischen wenn man Mainz Wiesbaden die
ja auf jeweils der anderen Rheinseite
liegen sich anschauen Rheinland-Pfalz
regierten seit langem eine Ampel in
Wiesbaden in Hessen Schwarz-Grün auch
das schimpfen auf die Ampel ist dann
nicht unbedingt glaub für unseren
Herbert da drüben funktioniert doch
einigermaßen da merkt man schon dass so
klassische Lager schon noch da sind in
den Köpfen aber einfach nicht mehr
Mehrheiten haben und das führt dann
genau zu diesem Eindruck dass das
irgendwie ein Spiel sei jeder weiß doch
dass am Ende irgendwas rauskommen muss
naja und für so ein spielerischen Blick
auf Politik sind Bürgerinnen und Bürger
nicht sehr empfänglich und ist natürlich
auch ein Akteur im politischen System
der genau das aufzufangen sucht nämlich
die AFD also das macht gerade
Landespolitik jedes Bundesland hat fast
eine andere Koalition inzwischen
wirklich schwierig in der Vermittlung
dass es noch um die Sache geht und nicht
nur um irgendwelche Farben Spieler und
die die wir früher die großen
Volksparteien genannt haben sind halt
eben auch nicht mehr große Parteien und
das macht eben auch noch mal
komplizierter ich würde ganz gerne auf
die Union gucken jetzt haben wir ein
bisschen auf die Ampel gesprochen
sie waren letzten Teil einer Sendungen
der Kollegen von Welt der hat Friedrich
Merz als parteivor der Union hat eine
Aussage gemacht zu Zahnbehandlung von
Asylbewerbern und hat sehr viel Kritik
dazu bekommen wie was war das ihrer
Meinung nach diese Aussage jetzt auch
gerade in dem Wahlkampf so klar
ja ein Bild zu bedienen was viele sagen
das ist populistisch ist ja die Union
ist natürlich
in einer Lage in der auf der einen Seite
die Migrationspolitik der Ampel als sehr
kritisch gesehen wird von den
Wählerinnen und Wählern aber auf der
anderen Seite quasi dieses diesen Frust
mit der Frust mit der Regierung nicht
auf dem Konto im positiven Sinne der CDU
einzahlt sondern wir sehen eben das in
der Migrationsfrage die größte Kompetenz
der AFD zugesprochen wird in unseren
eigenen Erhebungen und das ist natürlich
glaube die Frage wie man da als
konservative demokratische Partei drauf
reagiert die ist ungefähr so alt wie wie
die CDU selbst und da gibt's eben
verschiedene Blickweisen drauf ich
glaube also ich habe nichts anderes
gehört von Friedrich März seitdem hat es
aber auch nicht minütlich verfolgt ich
glaube er meint das so wie es sagt und
es auch überzeugt davon dass er an der
Stelle
Menschen aus der Seele spricht oder
quasi die Sorgen der Bürger ernst nimmt
und sie dort abholt ob das richtig ist
so zu handeln oder irgendwie auch das
spalterische hervorzuheben und auch
Menschengruppen gegeneinander
auszuspielen das kann man sicherlich
diskutieren aber ich denke dass er das
dass es nicht nur reines Kalkül war
sondern dass er auch der Überzeugung ist
hier muss irgendeine andere Struktur
rein und also hier muss quasi mehr
Kontrolle rein und das ist nicht meine
Meinung das war mein Eindruck aus der
Sendung wie ist das hier in Berlin
angekommen und auch innerhalb der Union
dieser Aussage von Friedrich Merz und
hilft die zum Beispiel Boris rein in
Hessen
glaube ich auf keinen Fall dass sie ihm
hilft es ist auch eher unser zumindest
unter führenden unions Leuten kritisch
bewertet worden weil der der Eindruck
entsteht oder oder eben nicht der
Eindruck entsteht ein März hat ein
Konzept das er sagt also pass mal
aufhören müssen wir über die Belastung
des Gesundheitssystems durch
Asylbewerber reden das ist ja eine
Debatte die man führen kann und da gibt
es ja auch seriöse Erkenntnisse
logischerweise das ist eine Belastung
gibt es sind einfach viele Menschen und
die mitgehen ins Gesundheitssystem das
könnte man ja machen das war der Satz
von März aber ja gerade nicht dass er
nicht der Versuch zu sagen und übrigens
morgen stellen wir unser Konzept vor wie
man das Gesundheitssystem entlassen kann
sondern hat das Ding rausgehauen die
Zähne machen ist auch ein ganz klarer
belegt das heißt schöner als OP ähm das
wissen wir
die lassen sich die Zähne machen und
andere bekommen keinen Termin ja also
auch wir hatten gleich am Tag danach
denn ich weiß gar nicht mehr den
Vorsitzenden ist es des deutschen
Zahnärzte Bundes der gesagt hat das
Problem ist nicht dass wir keine
Patienten in den
zu viele Patienten da haben sondern dass
er zu wenig sind dass wir kein Personal
haben das ist unser Problem also man hat
den Eindruck es war nicht ein Baustein
in einem in einer Diskussion die man
führen kann von der vielleicht auch
manche Krankenhausärzte sagen die müssen
wir führen sondern es war halten März
fragen sollte Äußerungen Frau Regel dazu
bei dass insgesamt dann der tonschärfe
naja also wenn Personen wie Friedrich
Merz die sehr prominent für eine
Volkspartei oder vielleicht ehemals
Volkspartei stehen
der gleichen Dinge sagen dann erweckt es
den Eindruck dass man das so sagen kann
und dass es eben nicht nur
Rechtspopulisten bis hin zur
rechtsradikalen oder menschenfeindliche
Gruppen oder Parteien sagen also es
rückt es verrückt sozusagen diesen
Bereich es verschiebt den Bereich des
Sagbaren und das ist tatsächlich halte
ich für ein Problem und ich würde ihnen
völlig zustimmen wenn das eingebettet
ist in eine gesundheitspolitische
Diskussion oder in diese Kombination von
Migrationsfragen und und
gesundheitspolitischen fragen wäre das
was anderes aber ich bin mir also gut
wir können Friedrich Merzen nicht in den
Kopf hineinschauen aber ich würde
unterstellen dass der schlau genug ist
dass er ziemlich genau weiß was er sagt
und er versucht oder die die Ruf will ja
ganz stark natürlich auch Stimmen von
der AFD zurückholen her fast weil da
gibt es ja klare
wählerwanderungen sozusagen hilft das
dann also wie oder wie sehr Stimmen
Union und AFD in all diesen Punkten
na die Übereinstimmung ist an vielen
Stellen schon da sie haben ja
eingangszene Wahlomat erwähnt dass es
sicher nicht die die die sozusagen
detaillierteste Analyse von
wahlprogrammatik aber trotzdem sieht man
da an vielen Stellen dass die AFD
natürlich eine Partei rechts der Mitte
ist wie auch die CDU in
unterschiedlichem Ausmaß ich will das
jetzt gar nicht gleichsetzen aber wenn
man sich den Wahlomat anschaut sind ja
diese bekannten 38 Thesen in den
Bundesländern dann stimmen die beiden
Parteien in ungefähr 80% der Fälle
überein also da ist schon eine
Schnittmenge das heißt nicht dass man
das alles so völlig problemlos
miteinander verrechnen kann aber da gibt
es eine gewisse Nähe und wenn ich einmal
hier auch wenn dann nicht gewählt wird
Thüringen reinwerfen darf dann war das
ja auch genau die Argumentation die wir
da gehört haben das ist Punkt zu erleben
schnittmen gibt wenn man es noch mal mit
dem migrationsthema verknüpfen muss man
aber glaube ich sich klar machen und
auch noch mal vergegenwärtigen was
passiert da eigentlich an so einem
Wahlsonntag ja und wenn wir im Vorfeld
ganz viel über Migration reden dann
gehen eben auch viele Wählerinnen und
Wähler in die Wahlkabinen denken genau
an dieses Thema weil es einfach sehr
sehr präsent ist und dann kommt genau
dieser Punkt wen halten sie dort
eigentlich für kompetent an wen denken
sie dann wiederum parteipolitisch
insofern fällt es mir schwer zu sehen
wie das der Union am Ende nutzen kann
weil dann greift diese etwas leere
Formel vom Original wählen was man die
so ganz genau was das heißen soll aber
es gibt eben eine Verbindung zwischen
Migration und AFD und bei vielen Wahlen
schon erlebt das macht mir so ein
bisschen Sorgen mit Blick auf den
Sonntag dass dieses Thema Migration was
den Menschen unter den Nägeln brennt was
auch nicht sehr differenziert diskutiert
wird am Ende tatsächlich durch das
unschöne Auswirkungen haben könnte
sozusagen zur Rhetorik und Verhandlung
noch mal was nehmen wir hatten ja 25 15
bei der sozusagen ersten großen
Bewegungen und migrationsbewegung diese
extreme Kritik an Angela Merkel dass sie
die Tore geöffnet hat mit wir schaffen
das was was sozusagen ein bisschen dabei
ist ja auch geblieben was dabei
runtergefallen ist dass sie ja bereits
Ende des Jahres 2015 den das Abkommen
mit Herrn Erdogan eingefädelt hat was ja
sagen wir mal schon ziemlich schmutziger
Deal war und wir schieben Milliarden
rüber um eine Regierung von der wir
wissen dass es eben ein autoradisches
Regime ist damit die ihre Grenzen zu
machen damit die Leute daran hindern in
die gummibote zu steigen und nach
Griechenland zu fahren also die selbe
Angela Merkel die nach außen hin eine
eine sehr humane Rhetorik vertreten hat
hat dann und das war wirkungsvoll die
Zahlen sind zurückgegangen der Türkei
Deal war eines der wenigen neben der
Grenzschließung auf der Balkanroute
durch Ungarn und Co war das der
wirkungsvollste Mechanismus also da muss
man eben immer sehen wer schreit und wer
handelt wird aber jetzt von der Union ja
nicht mehr so dargestellt nur nach vorne
gebracht ja das stimmt schon aber
gleichzeitig sagt man ja wir müssen
trinken mit dasselbe nachbauen mit den
afrikanischen Ländern funktioniert zum
Mittel okay also da sieht man das und
das Thema ist eben enorm wichtig wird
ist das auch ein Thema Frau Riegel wo
man sagt das wird also da muss man
besonders aufpassen dass da der Ton
nicht besonders scharf ist oder wie das
könnten oder wird auf der anderen Seite
aber wird den Grünen ja vorgeworfen dass
sie bestimmte Probleme vielleicht nicht
genug sehen also vielleicht zum ersten
Teil der Frage ich denke das ist
verschiedene Politikfelder gibt die
dafür geeignet sind so Polarisierung
aufzuziehen und ein wir gegen die zu
konstruieren und das ist ja so ein
bisschen auch die Idee dass man bei so
populistischen sprech so wie hier unten
gegen die da oben und bei der
Migrationsfrage geht einfach relativ
leicht dass man sagt also wir also als
die interne Gruppe gegen die da draußen
deswegen da ist vielleicht ein bisschen
leichter ob man da besonders aufpassen
muss ich würde vielleicht da an der
Stelle auch noch mal aus Perspektive von
einem Politiker schauen will finden wir
haben immer wir haben das sehr deutlich
20 18 in Bayern gesehen Markus Söder hat
in Anbetracht der Migrationsthematik und
Fragen innerer Sicherheit sehr nah in
Richtung AF gefischt auch so bei den
Migrationsfragen ist damit fürchterlich
auf die Nase gefallen und jetzt hat er
in dieser aktuellen Debatte wo man ja
das ist ja auch wieder so ein
wegschieben von landespolitischen Themen
also es ist ja ein relativ wenig was man
landespolitisch daran machen kann ja und
jetzt greift das wieder auf ja also zum
Sachleistungen und dergleichen kann man
diskutieren aber die großen Linien
sozusagen der Migrationspolitik zum
bundespolitische Fragen und jetzt greift
greift das wieder auf und macht aber ein
Dreh in dem gibt dem ganzen nämlich so
eine humane Perspektive also wir sind
die Partei von Lorent oder aber mit so
einem humaneren Konzept als es die AFD
macht das heißt man kann die Themen
schon bespielen und ich denke auch dass
das funktionieren kann und man da jetzt
nicht so Logik machen muss man muss hier
besonders vorsichtig sein auf der einen
Seite und auf der anderen Seite ja die
Grünen haben anderen Zugriff da drauf
und es ist so also das jetzt vielleicht
auch noch mal mit Blick auf Bayern man
möchte Welcome Center haben und es ist
in Anbetracht der Tatsache dass wir eine
sehr hitzige Matte aktuell haben ist es
etwas was den Menschen aufstößt und was
auch sozusagen in den Kommunen unter
Umständen auch aufstößten und dass man
sagt ja also bei aller Liebe man kann
vielleicht das ein oder andere dann auch
nicht schaffen man hat aber jetzt dann
bundesinnenministerin die sagt ja wir
sind für stärkere Grenzkontrollen die
also viele Dinge die in der SPD auch
durchaus kontrovers diskutiert wurden
die auf einmal jetzt das macht sie das
aber das zahlt bei ihr nicht ein das
Kandidatin vermutlich nicht obwohl es
durchaus da natürlich eine Verbindung
gäbe über ihr Amt tatsächlich aber laut
Umfragen
ist es trotzdem wissen wir tatsächlich
dass das für die SPD ein durchaus
gefährliches Thema sein kann was es dann
manchmal eher so zu schließen geht
abzusichern geht wenn man ein Auto
Schilling ganz früher auch denkt dann
bitte Regeln aber nicht groß
polarisieren und politisieren dass die
SPD mit einem solchen Thema Wahlen
gewinnen das wäre tatsächlich eine
Premiere also insofern das das sollte
man einfach man muss einfach sehen dass
es das ist gewisse grundverbindungen
zwischen Parteien und Themen gibt gar
nicht so sehr Positionen unbedingt
sondern dass die politische Agenda als
solche auch Wirkung entfalten kann
insofern würde sich im vorfelser
wahrscheinlich wünschen dass man über
Sozialpolitik vielleicht auch
Arbeitsmarktpolitik redet aber dafür
steht sie eben nicht und das scheint mir
so ein wenig die Herausforderung dieses
Wahlkampfs zu sein
die Herausforderung ist dass dieses die
Zuschreibung der Kompetenz auf ganz ganz
vielen Themen immer weiter Richtung AFD
reicht ne und das hat nichts damit zu
tun glaube ich dass man bei der AFD
schon mal erlebt hat wie gut sie die
Dinge anpacken wir sehen das in unserem
Erhebung dass sie selbst bei Fragen der
dass die welche Partei am ehesten das zu
einer Lage ist die Verwaltung zu
digitalisieren auch da trenne die AFD
ganz weit oben das ist natürlich
vollkommener Quatsch das kann man gar
nicht also das kann niemand wissen wie
die Hefte das angehen wird sie war noch
nie in der Funktion aber das ist
natürlich eine Gefahr also das ist
aber auch immer das Thema Migration
besprechen müssen und schon fragen warum
das jetzt in den letzten Wochen so stark
in den Mittelpunkt gerückt ist vor den
Wahlen weil wenn ich in unsere Daten
schaue dann steigt die Sorge vor
Migration seit 21 kontinuierlich an also
es wird ein immer wichtigeres Thema in
den in den Augen der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger und wir kennen auch die Beiträge
dass die Kommunen sich beklagen aber
interessanterweise ist jetzt das auf die
Aufmerksamkeit jetzt kurz vor den Wahlen
da und damit setzt man natürlich auch
Themen stärker für zur Wahl entscheiden
setzen narrative und das muss man sich
da muss man schon mal hinterfragen auch
bei der Frage woher kommt die Sorge von
Migration also wenn man die Frage ob man
die Medien die wie sehen sie wie
beobachten sie ihre eigene Diskussion in
Redaktion ist das ein Thema was auch ähm
ja was was jetzt auf einmal viel mehr
Aufmerksamkeit bekommt als andere Themen
na gut die Zahlen sind natürlich so wie
sie sind also erstens haben wir etwa
eine Million Menschen die durch den
Ukraine kriegt zu uns gekommen sind ist
zwar eine andere Akzeptanz
also so lange ist es noch nicht mal zwei
Jahre so und das ist sind einfach sehr
viele Menschen und gleichzeitig lesen
wir ja seit längerem wie wie sozusagen
der Zuzug der der eben nicht
ukrainischen
Migranten auch stärker zunimmt und wir
haben bis hin zu vielen grünen
Kommunalpolitikern inzwischen die
Notrufe die sagen das geht nicht mehr
also es ist ja kein erfundenes Problem
sondern es ist ja ein faktisches Problem
das ist da wir haben eine inkonsistente
Politik wo wir auf der einen Seite auf
Frau Feser die die
Grenzkontrollen Bayern Österreich immer
wieder verlängert und uns gleichzeitig
eine ganze Weile erzählt hat aber bei
Sachsen Polen hat es überhaupt keinen
Sinn dann sagt sie hat doch Sinn dann
hat das so einen halben Sinn also dass
die Leute dann natürlich wenn dann noch
Streit dazu kommt und man den Eindruck
hat konsistent ist da gar nichts dann
die Flüge nach
Nordafrika wo auch selbst die EU dabei
war wo wir feststellen das funktioniert
nicht die Tunesien die sagen eure paar
Millionen wollen wir gar nicht also im
Grunde gibt es ein echtes Problem
bisschen zu der Frage was wird aus
unserer Turnhalle und wie sieht es in
unserer Gemeinde aus und eine Politik
von denen die eine
die handeln kann nicht konsistent ist
und die anderen ziemlich rumkrakeelen
aber was ist dann dann
ja vielleicht einfach noch als Ergänzung
weil mein Eindruck schon ist dass es
eben nicht nur um Migrationspolitik geht
sondern es geht eben auch um
Bildungspolitik also in Hessen wie in
Bayern das ist ein Thema
Entbürokratisierung also das ist auch
etwas also das treibt auch Markus Söder
so durch den Wahlkampf immer wieder
Entbürokratisierung und ihm wird dann
umgekehrt dann vorgeworfen und den
Oppositionsparteien dass die ähm
bisherige Koalition das sozusagen nicht
besser konnte das würde ich sagen
Energiepolitik ist auch ein großes Thema
also ich meine Eindruck ist eher
Migrationspolitik ist etwas was jetzt
gerade so ein bisschen Push aber auf der
anderen Seite gibt es über die Wahlkampf
über die heiße Phase des Wahlkampf schon
auch noch andere Themen aber natürlich
auch dass wir keine lö sung also ich
lachen wenn Markus Söder sagt wir machen
jetzt mal in der Energiepolitik was wir
hatten verhindert dass die großen
Leitungen für den der Nürnberger Energie
nach Bayern kommen das war halt so
wieder zusammen mit Herrn Seehofer wer
hat bei der bei der bei den
Genehmigungsverfahren für windradbau war
Bayern jetzt auch nicht gerade vorne
Abstandsregelung das sind ja alles
Bürokratisierung fahren habe ich das
Wort Entbürokratisierung zum ersten Mal
gehört es muss kurz nach meiner
Grundschule gehen
Markus Söder diese Widersprüche
nicht auf die Füße fallen also jetzt
man zumindest nicht also wir werden
jetzt alles gucken was am Sonntag
rauskommt aber er sieht auch als wenn in
der Einzelbewertung der Kandidaten also
wenn ich irgendwie Menschen in
Deutschland Frage nach Markus Söder
Fragen haben sie sofort ein Bild vor
Augen sie wissen genau wer ist wofür er
steht dass er heute mal dafür steht und
morgen mal dafür aber auch das ist
irgendwie in sich konsistent 36 % den
Umfragen glaube ich genau und 37 bei uns
aber CSU werden persönlich
als Person also es gibt keinen
Ministerpräsidenten und keine
Ministerpräsidenten ansonsten in
Deutschland die auf solche
bekanntheitswerte kommen und auf eine
solche zuordbarkeit Zuordnung Zuordnung
bekommen genau weiß was man hat auch
wenn sich das morgen ändern kann aber
dann ist es immer noch
wer ist Boris rein dann wissen
wahrscheinlich nicht also der hessische
Spitzenkandidat der Union seit
anderthalb Jahren Abend ist wieder auf
eine weitere Debatte über die
Kanzlerkandidatur helfen dürfen ja das
wird noch kommen
so sehr das Ding auch die letzte
Bundestagswahl ja für seinen für seine
Partei durchaus heute für die Union
durchaus mit in den Abgrund getrieben
hat na klar kommt er in Frage und eben
weil er der Ministerpräsident ist der
einfach bekannt ist wird er auch wieder
im Spiel sein eine gewisse Ironie auch
hat nur wir reden über 36 %. was
wahrscheinlich einer der höchsten Werte
in Deutschland ist die ist für ein paar
Tage gibt aber für die CSU natürlich ihn
weit weg von dem was sie möchte und mein
dass die CSU kurzen Prozess macht in der
Fraktion in der Partei das haben wir nun
bei Edmund Stoiber beispielsweise der
damals glaube ich weit über 40% stand
erlebt also insofern natürlich ist er
ein bundespolitisches bekannter Akteur
aber wir müssen schon auch sehen die
Nervosität in der CSU in Bayern einmal
Stichwort neues Wahlrecht sagen sie
müssen nach bundesweit über 5% kommen
also da ist schon Nervosität da und
bisher hat er keine einzige Wahl
gewonnen und wenn er das am Sonntag
wieder nicht schafft
40 % geholt und macht daraus ein
schwarz-grünes Bündnis also der ist ja
der Gegenentwurf wie man über 40% kommt
aber ich würde da tatsächlich
widersprechen also ja das Wahlergebnis
wird aller Voraussicht nach noch
schlechter sein als 20 18 und ich denke
auch es wird interne Diskussionen geben
und ja wir evaluieren das alles und
besprechen das aber ich glaube ihm wird
es gut gelingen diesmal so diese
Kontextfaktoren zu bestimmen und zu
deutlich zu machen warum er als
Ministerpräsident eher als
Spitzenkandidat gar nichts für das
schlechte Ergebnis kann das sind halt
die Umstände die Freien Wähler Hubert
Aiwanger und so weiter
oder die Zustimmung der Freien Wähler
hat nicht gelitten unter der Diskussion
über das Flugblatt fromm ist wie
erklären sie das denn dass das so ist
ja also
Hubert also genau wir haben sehr also
wir haben keine Bestrafung für die
Freien Wähler messen können oder für
Hubert einwanger im Gegenteil es hat
unter den eigenen WLAN eher eine Art
solidaritätswelle ist ausgelöst worden
wir haben zwischenzeitlich über also wir
steigende Zustimmungswerte für die
Freien Wähler gemessen andere haben sie
eher bei der AFD gemessen aber in jedem
Fall sind Sie bei der CSU kurzfristig
runtergegangen was natürlich auch für
Markus Söder für die CSU es war eine
lösungssituation da hätte man
kurzfristig glaube ich nichts gewinnen
können
um Führung zu signalisieren ich glaube
es war eine ganz ganz schwere Situation
rein und politisch also spieltheoretisch
drauf schaut
ich denke das hat einfach was damit zu
tun was das Wähler Klientel also wie das
Fehler Klientel von Hubert Aiwanger
drauf schaut und
das ist einfach die eigenen das eigene
Klientel empfindet das nicht als so
schlimm wie das eben in der in den
Medien veröffentlicht und überbracht
wurde das mag man kritisch finden und
aber tatsächlich messen mir da keine
keine kritere eigene Lager wenn Söder
jetzt nicht in eiwanger festgehalten
hätte wäre es noch schwieriger gewesen
also ich würde argumentieren von Anfang
an ist das größte Problem in dieser
ganzen Flugblatt causa für Söder gewesen
definitiv vor allem weil jetzt außerhalb
Bayerns Deutschland festgestellt hat der
Mann hat gar keine allein Regierung ich
meine das ist ihm ja ganz gut gelungen
nach der letzten Wahl den Eindruck
erwecken
CSU regiert Bayern wie immer
aufgefallen na klar wenn man ihn aber
jetzt seit ein paar Wochen also das das
muss man sagen weiß wirklich jeder dass
er Söder nicht alleine mit der CSU
Bayern regiert jetzt hatte noch die
jetzt steigen auch noch die Werte für
seinen Koalitionspartner also das
Märchen ist beendet und hinzu muss man
aber auch sagen dass die
Zustimmungswerte für die Freien Wähler
schon im Juli rum angefangen haben zu
steigen juni julia ist schon früher ein
bisschen so eine Entwicklung gewesen und
es ist so die meisten Wählerinnen und
Wähler wählen die Freien Wähler wegen
Hubert eiwanger also die freien sind
sicherlich deutlich heterogener als
Hubert Aiwanger ist aber da gibt es noch
mehr aber die Wellen die werden die
Freien Wähler wegen ihm und ihm gelingt
es einfach diese doch sehr ausgeprägte
Konfliktlinie die ist in Bayern gibt
nämlich die zwischen Zentrum und
Peripherie oder zwischen Stadt und Land
einfach noch mal deutlicher zu bespielen
und wir sie auch gesagt haben würde ich
absolut zustimmen Hubert alban hat eine
ziemlich eingeschworene
unterstützerschaft und das ist auch das
was wir bei unseren Analysen in dem
spartaprojekt gesehen haben wie die
Stimmung für die Freien Wähler nach der
nach Erding nach der flugplatzaffäre
hochgegangen sind auch in diesem ähm ja
in so einem Ticker konnte man fast
beobachten
trotzdem indem er so klar gesagt hat
Söder wir möchten diese bürgerliche
Koalition fortsetzen gibt es eigentlich
keinen Grund mehr CSU zu wählen und da
hätte er glaube ich schon andere
Optionen gehabt zu sagen natürlich
bringen wir das gut zu Ende wir haben
gut zusammengearbeitet und danach wird
man sehen was passiert nicht mit den
Grünen das hat er ja immer gesagt aber
sozusagen sich so an die freien Wähler
zu binden führt eigentlich für Leute die
mit dieser Koalition zufrieden sind dazu
dass sie das ist eigentlich egal ist
oder frei Wähler wählen alles andere
profitiert oder nutzt den Grünen also
ich glaube da wird man rückblickend
diese 25 Fragen die seltsam Antworten
ich meine da wurde ein Ministerpräsident
eigentlich bloßgestellt dass er sich das
hatten lassen
muss eigentlich der CSU sehr sehr weh
tun schau mal noch mal auf die andere
auf die Kanzlerpartei denn immerhin
stellt die SPD den den Bundeskanzler
viele in der Ampel gab es genügend
Streit wie inwieweit ist das ein Punkt
dass der dass der Bundeskanzler sich
vielleicht auch nicht so stark einmischt
der dann darauf einfällt dass die SPD
nicht so sichtbar ist oder dass man
nicht so genau weiß wofür die SPD steht
auch in dieser Ampel und hat das
Auswirkungen auf den Landtagswahlen wer
möchte
natürlich haben wir sagen wir mal nach
dem ersten Jahr Ampel wo ja doch die
Dominanz des Ukraine Themes so war dass
man den Eindruck hatte dieses in einer
erstaunliches koordiniert ist
harmonisches Handeln in dieser neuen
Konstellation begann ja dann Phase 2 mit
dem zweiten Jahr und da haben natürlich
die Zerrissenheit oder die Gräben waren
vor allen Dingen zwischen FDP und Grünen
was eben auch zur Folge hat dass man die
besonders wahrgenommen hat die SPD stand
ein bisschen im Hintergrund und wollte
mal ein bisschen hier beruhigt ein
bisschen da beruhigt aber damit machen
sie natürlich keine wirklichen Punkte
man hatte ja selten den Eindruck dass
der Scholz sagt so also mit dem
heizungsgesetz machen wir es jetzt so
ich räume hier mal die Bude auf sondern
nein wir machen 30 Stunden
dauerkonditionsverhandlungen und danach
sind wir eigentlich auch nicht richtig
weiter das war ja bisher alles nicht
überzeugend im Sinne von der Führung
bestellt der bekommt auch Führung von
mir jetzt hat er bald bei dem Asyl bei
der europäischen Asylpolitik wieder so
ein Ding gemacht und kaum hat er gesagt
so wir verhindern gar nichts in Brüssel
gegen das da schon wieder los also ein
kanzlerbonus gibt es wieder in Bayern
noch in Hessen einfach ich würde die
beiden Länder an der Stelle wirklich
auseinanderhalten wollen in Bayern zeigt
wirklich ein Strukturproblem der SPD in
bayerische SPD war immer stark in
Städten und da haben in die Grünen
einfach den Rang abgelaufen und das
sehen wir auch in vielen anderen
Bundesländern nur ist die SPD oder
sozusagen von ihrer Grundstruktur etwas
breiter aufgestellt also
Bayern ist für die SPD einstellig das
tut unglaublich weh aber man sieht auch
nicht so wirklich wie daraus was anderes
erwachsen soll Hessen ist ein bisschen
anders zumal auch in Hessen die
Koalitionsfrage tatsächlich sehr sehr
offen ist und dieses schwarz-grüne
Bündnis zwar recht reibungslos
funktioniert hat aber die persönliche
Chemie zwischen rein und alvarsia jetzt
nicht die beste sein soll also ich bin
gespannt was da am Ende rauskommt aber
auch das ist natürlich am Ende wenn das
sich bewahrheitet was wir als zahlen als
Umfrage Zahlen gerade so sehen 16 17 %
für die SPD nichts was man sich erhofft
hatte das muss man auch ganz klar sagen
aber das ist tatsächlich auch noch mal
was spannendes auf der Zielgeraden was
auch noch mal wirklich für Dynamik
Sorgen haben so eine Reihe von Parteien
die mit der 5% Hürde kämpfen wir haben
eine Reihe von Kandidaten für den
zweiten Platz das löst manchmal noch so
Dynamik aus insofern warten wir mal den
Sonntag aber das sind so sich noch mal
alles umdreht ob man das Haus intern
anders sieht wenn man zahlen hat aber
das wäre schon sehr sehr überraschend
nachdenken Hessen ist es spannend das
eigentlich keine der Kandidaten wirklich
zufrieden sein kann also der amtieren
Ministerpräsident hat seinen Amtsbonus
nicht wirklich gut ausgespielt viele
Menschen im Land kennen ihn eigentlich
weiterhin nicht können mit ihnen nicht
richtig was können nicht richtig was
zuordnen die bundesinnenministerin hat
ehrenamtsbonus auch nicht wirklich gut
ausgespielt auch Tarek engagiert also
der ist eigentlich seit Jahrzehnten kann
man fast sagen eine Figur in der
hessischen Politik auch von ihm hätte
man sicherlich vor einigen Monaten mehr
erwartet ich denke da ist aktuell
niemand wirklich zufrieden
und ich würde auch noch mal da ergänzen
wollen nämlich diese nicht sehr klare
Bekanntheit und vielleicht auch nicht
die besonders hohen Zustimmungswert für
einen rein auf der einen Seite finde ich
machen schon auch noch mal oder
unterstreichen schon auch noch mal dass
es auf der anderen Seite finanziell
fazer ein Kanzler Malus bzw eine
regierungs- an der Stelle gibt weil
genau genommen wäre sie vielleicht
thematisch gar nicht so eine schlechte
Wahl gewesen also NSU 20 Lübke Hanau das
sind ja und sie steht ja für genau diese
themenbekämpfung des Rechtsextremismus
rechtsextremer Gewalt hat genau also die
Ausgangslage hätte gut sein können und
das also sie man bringt überhaupt nicht
auf die Straße an der Stelle und ich
denke schon dass da der Bundestrend
schon auch in Hessen kräftig mit
reinspielt der bundestrand ist wichtig
und dann ist er die Frage was dann was
dann andererseits je nachdem wie diese
Wahlen ausgehen was das dann wieder
zurückfolgerungen und dann hier fürs
Regieren hat was erwarten sie da wird da
sagen wir mal die FDP die in beiden
Ländern wo nicht klar ist die wirklich
einen klaren Einzug schaffen wird sich
die muss sich ja dann auch noch mal
anders profilieren also was wird was
wird daraus folgt das wird sich
fortsetzen fangen wir mit der FDP mal an
also da gibt es ja nur die Möglichkeit
zwischen dem schlechten und einem
katastrophalenausgang im Grunde genommen
das heißt die werden eher ihr in den
letzten Monaten ja schon deutlich zu
erkennende Eigenständigkeit noch stärker
betonen und noch mehr betonen und noch
noch häufiger
gegen auch die die grundvereinigung die
grüne Linie in der Regierung angehen ob
das funktioniert weiß ich nicht in der
in der einzigen FDP CDU-Regierung wie es
mit Frau Merkel gab hat die FDP sogar
Mitgliederbefragung gegen gegen die
Europapolitik gemacht anschließend sind
sie aus dem Bundestag geflogen also bin
ich sicher ob so ein randaliermodell
wirklich auf Dauer funktioniert zweitens
ist die Niederlage von Frau Feser
vielleicht so dermaßen schwer das doch
eine Dynamik hier in Berlin entsteht wo
man sagt wie kann ich einfach als
Innenminister weiter machen also ich
rechne erstmal Scholz ist ja jetzt kein
begeisterter Kabinetts und bildender
bisher das macht er wirklich wenn es gar
nicht mehr anders geht wenn der
sozusagen per
Silvester Video angefleht wird bitte
schmeiß mich raus dann vermutlich macht
er das hat
zu sagen ich bleibe wenn ich nicht
Ministerpräsidentin werde ich nehme mal
an das bleibt nur ich sage es gibt
Dynamiken die könnten dann noch dazu
führen so dann geht der Scholz mal
gucken wie viele andere Probleme hatte
ihr unglückliches agieren mit dem Chef
des Bundesamt für Sicherheit so aber
natürlich nicht zehn Bewerberinnen die
die morgen im Innenministerium anfangen
könnten also insofern da wird er etwas
vorsichtig sein frau Kaiser raus zu
schmeißen ich nehme mal an sie bleibt
ich würde ganz gerne zum Schluss noch
mal eine Runde machen wie wir vielleicht
auf einen anderen Ton kommen wenn wir
sagen der sie haben das nochmal klar
auch gesagt dass der Ton sich so
verschärft und wenn man jetzt wir haben
nächstes Jahr drei Landtagswahlen in
ostdeutschen Bundesländern wenn das
jetzt so weiter an Fahrt aufnehmen dann
ist es ja schlecht fürs ganze Land wie
kriegt man das hinkommen mit was wir was
oder wir haben gibt es da
Aussagen drüber dass Menschen sagen sie
sie haben mir vorhin das schon
angedeutet dass man da weniger streiten
wie kriegt man das hin ich glaube es
geht gar nicht um weniger Streit es geht
darum dass man das Gefühl hat dass
dieser Streit auch in etwas
produktivemündet und ich glaube dass
dann ist Streit auch in Ordnung aus sich
der Wähler das zweite Problem aus Sicht
der Wähler ist dass die Themen die ihnen
auf ihn Lasten dass sie das Gefühl haben
die werden nicht adressiert also ich
glaube das ist wirklich ein
kommunikationsfrage da das Gefühl es
wird sich eigentlich nur ein Klimaschutz
beschäftigt dem ist aber gar nicht so
und das kriegt die Ampel Regierung nicht
so gut übermittelt und ja der Rest aus
meiner Position ich wünsche mir das dass
politische Akteure dann anderen Ton
hinkriegen weil das wäre wichtig denke
ich aber haben wir gerade so sind wir am
Anfang von so einem Wandel auch in der
politischen Kultur Herr FAS auch weil
die Volksparteien nicht mehr so sind wie
sie früher waren so stark und dann auch
und und so viele verschiedene
Koalitionen auch möglich sind ja da
kommen sicher viele Faktoren zusammen
Parteibindungen lassen nach Wahl
Teilnahme ist nicht im
selbstverständlich ich glaube trotzdem
dass es so ein gewisses innehalten nach
diesen beiden Landtagswahlen geben wird
sie haben es gerade gesagt nächstes Jahr
sind drei Wahlen in Ostdeutschland und
man kann nicht sehenden Auge sind eine
Situation laufen wo dann dort die AFD in
zwei oder drei Bundesländern die
stärkste Partei wird und das geht glaube
ich nur wenn man sich wirklich
zusammenreißt zwischen den anderen
Parteien und irgendwie den schmalen
gerade findet zwischen Streit aber
trotzdem auch bei der Sache bleiben
nicht den Eindruck erwecken dass es nur
um ein selbst Zweck geht bei dem man in
der Sache wie in Thüringen mit der AFD 1
ist aber das würde ich jetzt nicht jetzt
mit der Bundespartei unter dem
Bundesparteien tatsächlich das wird
spannend wie man sich dort abgrenzt aber
ich glaube tatsächlich es gibt ja auch
durchaus ein paar Signale und
Deutschland packt und auch von aus
selbst aus der CDU heraus Angebote sich
zusammenzusetzen und ich glaube das muss
passieren das wird auch passieren aber
im Moment ist dafür tatsächlich kein
Platz wenige Tage vor der Wahl oder den
Wahlen
noch schärfer jetzt wenn die Wahlen für
viele Parteien nicht so ausgehen wie sie
sich das gewünscht hätten ja das kann
gut sein und insgesamt muss ich zugeben
dass ich nicht so optimistisch bin also
ich denke dass die Parteien und die das
Spitzenpersonal sieht dass man mit
einfachen Antworten auf komplexe Fragen
in hoch aufgeheizten wahlkampfphasen
vielleicht doch die ein oder andere
Stimme für sich gewinnen kann und
Wahlkampf ist die Zeit wo es darum geht
Stimmen zu bekommen und das dann
sozusagen nach der Wahl wieder zu
befrieden und wieder zusammenzubringen
ist eine große Herausforderung und ich
sehe schon dass diese pol Regierung auch
der Parteiensysteme der auf Länderebene
und dem Bund dass das etwas ist was
zunimmt und das macht mir tatsächlich
Sorgen
welche Rolle könnten oder welche
positive Rolle könnten Medien da spielen
naja im Grunde genommen so viel
einen langsam aus der Mode geratenen
Begriff zu benutzen Aufklärung wie
möglich Aufklärungsarbeit und
beschreiben wie funktioniert die
Demokratie wie funktionieren Gesetze und
so weiter das heißt vielleicht
weniger auf Radau und mehr auf auf
inhaltliche Aufklärung glaube auch dass
die Leser das sehr gut Tieren wir merken
das auch wir merken das auch im Netz bei
uns ganz klar den Klicks auch ganz lange
Artikel aktiv die in die Tiefe gehen
werden gut geklickt und und das ist
schon auch gewollt die Leute sind nicht
so scharf darauf dass also
ununterbrochen Saal schlafen
dokumentiert werden
okay sind wir gespannt und hoffen dass
es dann am Sonntag alles ruhig bleibt in
Bayern und in Hessen vielen Dank Frau
Rede vielen Dank Herr Jose vielen Dank
Frau Mütze und Herr Faß den sie
natürlich als guter treuer Zuschauer von
Phoenix wissen sie das regelmäßig auch
im Podcast hören können mit unter 3 mit
dem Kollegen Erhard schärfer und die
frühlingsrunde gibt's übrigens auch als
Podcast
ein eigener Sache und wir sind natürlich
am Wahlsonntag ist Phönix natürlich wie
immer auch für Sie da und morgen sind
wir auch wieder damit einer Phönix Runde
und da schauen wir noch mal auf die
neuen globalen Entwicklungen ja die ist
rund um die Aufregung in den USA geht
aber auch eben jetzt um die
Europäische Union Thema Migration all
das zusammen reden wir morgen bis dann
tschüss
[Musik]